now it's common knowledge at this point
that pretty much every prediction that's
ever been made by climate activists has
turned out to be completely false but
for the most part all along there's one
thing these activists have been smart
enough to do which is they they've
typically made predictions that were
pretty far out into the future they
didn't say anything that could be proven
wrong you know within a couple of months
they knew uh enough to create some
distance between their prediction and
the day that you could theoretically
point to that prediction and say well
that didn't pan out and there are a lot
of examples of this phenomenon there's
uh Leonard nemoy aka Mr Spock claiming
in a 1978 television special that quote
during the lifetime of our grandchildren
arctic cold and Perpetual snow could
turn most of the inhabitable portions of
our planet into a polar desert that TV
special was called the coming Ice Age
and of course by the time Mr Spock's
prediction was falsified uh he was near
death so no one was going to hold him
accountable or say I told you so when he
was on his deathbed which I guess is
sort of understandable then there was
that famous 1989 article from the
Associated Press citing a senior un
environmental official saying that quote
entire nations could be wiped off the
face of the Earth by rising sea levels
if the global warming trend is not
reversed by the year
2000 now again they're putting some
distance between the prediction and the
time when you can prove that the
prediction was wrong a NASA scientist
did the same thing in 2006 when he told
NBC news that quote the world has a
10-year window of opportunity to take
decisive action on global warming and
avert catastrophe more recently of
course Greta thunberg got in on the
action in 2018 when she claimed that
quote a top climate scientist is warning
that climate change will wipe out all of
humanity unless we stop using fossil
fuels over the next 5 years now in all
these cases the climate predictions
weren't even close to being true reality
disproved all of them but it took time
for these predictions to age out and
become clearly false most cultists are
smart enough to design their claims so
that they sound highly alarming at the
time and then by the time that you can
validate those claims years later most
people have forgotten about the whole
thing and they've moved on to making
different claims that are farther in the
future still a couple of months ago
there was a very notable exception to
this general rule there was a cult
leader who slipped up and made a
prediction that could be proven wrong
very quickly I'm talking about the
prediction from uh our climate Zar John
ker and here's what he said this
summer The the climate crisis is growing
by the day you just saw have reported on
what happened in New York all around the
world there are record-breaking days
where the heat is greater than it's ever
been before this will be the hottest
June and July it'll be the hottest
summer it'll be the hottest year and we
all know that because the science is
telling it to us and because Mother
Earth is responding by telling us
exactly what's going
on now we've already established in the
past that uh of course it was never
going to be true that it's the hottest
year on record that's an absurd CL claim
uh or even you know what they've
actually said is it's the hottest year
period for the planet Earth which even
if that was true there would be no
possible way to uh to to verify that
because we don't have records of what
the temperature was on a daily basis
going back thousands and millions of
years but if you try to fact check that
claim from John kry you'll find a bunch
of Articles declaring that he was right
they'll say this is indeed the hottest
year ever and that's and it's all
because Mother Earth doesn't like your
truck or your grill or the way you vote
none of these articles will mention the
recent volcanic eruption in the Pacific
Ocean which we've talked about that
blasted a huge plume of water vapor into
the atmosphere they won't tell you how
that likely trapped heat and raised the
global temperatures instead they'll
blame you for all the Heat and what's
funny about this premise is that if we
accept it as completely true for the
sake of argument that humans uh caused
all this then humans must also be
responsible for the extremely cold
temperatures that are also being
recorded this year in some cases we're
being told record cold temperatures
turns out out it hasn't been hot
everywhere contrary to what John krey
says so take a look at what's happening
in Europe right now according to an
article from yesterday in Reuters for
example quote temperatures in Siberia
dip to minus 56 celsi as record snow
blankets Moscow in the Russian Capital
some of the biggest snowfalls ever seen
on seen on December 3rd left swaths of
Moscow blanketed in drifts of more than
35 cmers of snow in just one day now
most of Central and Eastern Europe was
uh like that last week they've never
seen snow like this in recorded history
this is supposedly the hottest year ever
recorded and their experiencing record
snowfall but it gets better because if
you want decisive proof that irony is
still alive despite every effort by the
left to quash it forever here it is the
snow was so bad last week that in Munich
the airport was completely covered in
snow private planes were immobilized and
in some cases Frozen in what looks like
a kind of a takeoff position position
because snow stacked up on their tail
sections and reportedly some of these
planes were supposed to head to the cop
28 climate Summit which is underway
right now in Dubai so you couldn't
script it any better here's what the
airport looked like in Munich just a
couple of days
[Music]
ago
so private jets are frozen on their way
to the climate Summit where the owners
of the Jets want to lect you about the
evils of global warming it's kind of
like a you know it's like a dietician
being late to a weight loss seminar
because his car broke down in the Taco
Bell drive through uh it's just too much
irony the climate evangelists have gone
full circle once again head headlong
into self- parody now in the interest of
full disclosure even though it kind of
ruins the joke I should clarify that uh
this particular plane you saw in the
video that you know it's been making the
rounds on social media um that uh we
don't know for a fact whether that
particular plane was heading to the cop
28 Summit According to some internet
sleuths who looked at this aircraft and
its registration number it was parked
for several days before this storm
arrived so we don't really know but we
can assume given the wide impact of this
torrential snowstorm all across Europe
that some travel PL for this cop 28
Summit were indeed disrupted and that is
among other things both deeply ironic
and extremely hilarious it's also not
the first time something like this has
happened in fact it's happened quite a
bit you can go all the way back to March
of 2009 when uh these nut jobs were
still using the term global warming
instead of climate change and they held
a big rally in the nation's capital they
were there to complain about how hot the
world was getting because apparently
warming climates is always a bad thing
even though it often makes it easier to
farm in huge portions of the world and
has many other benefits but never mind
that these climate activists Gather in
Washington DC to send the message that
the world was getting way too hot and uh
if if you don't recall this right on Q a
historic snowstorm completely shut down
the whole protest Let's uh watch that
and remember together on behalf of the
Speaker of the House ncy Pelosi and
Democratic Leadership I want to say
thank you for bringing the
reinforcements around the country so we
can get the job done this year
have been corrupted by this dirty filthy
industry how come we can't do this event
in August but it's nice and warm
out I have no answer for that question
do do you think we should try to make
this event like in August when it's
really warm well August and DC is pretty
miserable as well that's what I'm saying
so then you could give in every
Congressman to support global warming
legislation don't you think that they
should maybe uh do this in more
temporate climate
well it was warm when we got here right
and I would hope that our politicians
really understand that weather is
different from climate and just because
you have a snow storm doesn't mean that
global warming isn't happening but you
have to admit it sort of screws up the
photo off a little bit kind of yeah it's
kind of ironic do you think it'd be a
better idea to do this in
August um maybe it's a little I mean
it's burning in August and DC month and
so we're used to this weather the
majority of these people are um are
actually happy about the weather because
then it it gives them an opportunity to
show how you know devoted they are to
the ca there was so much snow that the
solar panels on green piece's truck were
totally snowed over so the solar panels
on the Greenpeace truck which read
America can stop global warming uh were
frozen over I guess proving that we can
I don't know it's a remarkable clip for
so many reasons for example you also
heard the now familiar retort from one
of the climate Act activist In that clip
and she insists that quote weather is
different from climate just because you
have a snowstorm doesn't mean the
warming isn't happening that's an
important line and again a very familiar
one we hear this all the time now that
weather is not the same as climat when
they talk about climate change you can't
it's not about weather but that's
totally false of course the the the uh
literal dictionary definition of climate
is the weather conditions prevailing in
in an area in general over a long period
that so that's climate is the prev in
weather conditions that's what the
climate is so saying that weather is
different from climate it's like saying
water is different from H2O it just
doesn't even make any sense and to the
extent that it does make sense it's not
true and you can tell the woman doesn't
really believe it you can tell she has
no idea what it what it's supposed to
mean because she laughs you know uh a
few seconds later about what she's
saying but it lets her reconcile the
fact that her beliefs are being
contradicted by reality right in front
of her gives her something to say in a
desperate attempt to avoid complete
humiliation
and that clip in retrospect belongs in
kind of a time capsule because it marked
one of the last times that climate
activists would ever talk about global
warming with a straight face again that
was sort of the end of global warming
unofficially and they transitioned very
soon afterwards to exclusively talking
about climate change instead of global
warming and the reason is obvious
climate change gives them a catchall
that they can always blame in any
context they don't have to risk any more
embarrassing photo ops where they're
whining about warming as they're being
pummeled by snow when the V villain is
climate change then you can complain
whether it's hot or snowy or doesn't
matter whatever is happening it proves
your claim that's the advantage of
talking about climate instead of warming
climate change is proven no matter what
happens it is unfalsifiable which is
also why it's false unfalsifiable
theories are at best useless theories
but are also false as the holiday season
unfolds it's a time of Joy gratitude and
reflection and in the midst of the
festivities consider taking a moment to
reflect on the digital footprint that
accompanies you throughout this season
think about all the information on your
phone from anything you search your
location to the websites you shop at and
more companies can then legally gather
this information and sell your data for
profit that's why you need to do what I
do and keep your data private with
expressvpn expressvpn is an app on your
phone and computer that encrypts all of
your online traffic so whatever you do
stays private if you think incognito
mode will stop people from tracking your
online activity think again when you
read the fine print that appears when
you start browsing in incognito mode it
says that your activity might still be
visible to your employer your school or
your internet service provider with
Express VPN every site you visit could
be logged by the Admin of that Network
we' love using expressvpn because of how
easy it is to use the app has one button
once you turn it on you're protected
from prying eyes it's as simple as that
the daily wire has partnered with
expressvpn to get you a special holiday
offer go to expressvpn.com Walsh rightow
and get three extra months free that's
Express V vpn.com walex RSS vpn.com
Walsh expressvpn.com Walsh to learn more
so this is how it's gone from Ice Age to
global warming to climate change getting
broader and less specific with each
change according to NASA quote global
warming became the dominant popular term
in June 1988 when NASA scientist James E
Hansen had testified to Congress about
climate specifically referring to global
warming but then people started to
notice that it was getting colder than
it had ever been before in 1994 for for
example the midwestern and Eastern
portions of the country experienced a
cold wave that caused more than a 100
deaths the country Saw's coldest
temperatures in nearly a century so once
again the Lexicon had to change as CNN
reports the term climate change quote
became more popular in the
2000s the point of all these changes
isn't isn't just to save face with every
change activists give themselves more
latitude to justify all of their other
political goals in the name of saving
the
environment at the cop 28 Summit the
other day John krey pledged to shut down
all coal power plants anywhere in the
world except presumably China which is
constantly opening new coal plants every
week and which doesn't remotely care
what John krey says about anything now
John K's plan would destroy the world
economy it would do precisely nothing to
stop the climate from changing because
the climate is always going to change
but you're supposed to think that it's a
reasonable thing to do because we're in
a climate emergency everything's on the
table Hill Clinton has been doing her
part to sound the alarm about this fake
emergency recently she insisted that
climate change is somehow killing people
due to uh extreme Heats and here's her
claim listen we're seeing uh and
beginning to pay attention and to count
and record uh the deaths that are
related to climate and by far the
biggest killer is extreme heat I mean
even in Europe last summer which uh has
the ability to count and figure figure
out what happened they recorded
61,000 deaths because of the heat in
Europe we don't have that kind of number
yet from Africa Asia Latin America but
we know and estimate that we probably uh
could uh measure about 500,000 deaths
and the majority of those are women and
girls and particularly pregnant
women now just as a factual matter Ju
Just you know none of that is true it's
not even close extreme cold kills far
more people than extreme heat just to
give one data point according to the
Lancet there were roughly 800 deaths due
to heat in England and Wales between
2000 and 2019 by contrast there were
more than 60,000 deaths associated with
extreme cold and Forbes reports that in
this country quote the cdc's national
Center for Health statistics compressed
mortality database which is based on
actual death certificates indicates that
roughly twice as many people die of cold
in a given year than of heat this is
kind of obvious when you think about it
someone who someone exposed to cold can
develop hypothermia literally within
minutes uh in most cases the heat will
not affect you that quickly or at all
even in like 90 degree temperatures if
you find a shady spot and have enough
water to drink you can lay around
outside all day and be perfectly fine
actually you'd be quite
pleasant but the point of what Hillary
Clinton was saying wasn't really about
extreme heat or extreme cold her goal is
to convince you that a lot of people are
dying due to the
climate effectively that's like saying a
lot of people are dying due to the fact
that they live on planet Earth by the
way I mean it's completely meaningless
talking about deaths related to climate
is like talking about deaths related to
physical
existence it's it's a category so broad
as to be
incoherent but you're just supposed to
buy into it and smile and wave as hordes
of so-called climate refugees flood into
this country which is really what this
is all about for her our Public Health
establishment meanwhile wants to use
climate change to explain away the next
fake pandemic which they can use to gain
even more control over your life here's
the TV expert Dr Peter hotz explaining
that climate change could be responsible
for the next covid watch why are we
seeing so many pandemics it's one of the
most common questions I've asked is it's
a Confluence of 21st century forces a
big one is climate change which is
altering the migration of animals that
can transmit these uh viral
pathogens yes we're experiencing Pand
good thing they experienced pandemics
back you know
historically like all those people
during the Black Death uh there's so the
pandemics are a new thing because of
climate change now whatever your
political affiliation there's always a
temptation to make arguments like this
two decades ago the establishment right
made the same arguments about the war on
terror they told us that terrorism was
an existential threat and therefore we
had assign away our rights to fisa
courts which very soon would be used by
the FBI to harass and imprison their
political opponents and now the left is
using climate change in much the same
way it's an unkillable ever evolving
enemy and in order to combat it we're
told that we need to destroy everything
that's important to
civilization to that end the Department
of Agriculture in Ireland recently
considered a plan to kill 200,000 cows
to reduce emissions so they're thinking
about literal animal sacrifice to save
the climate even though by the climate
alarm its own standards by the way
Ireland barely emits any CO2 in the
atmosphere at all in comparison to many
other countries now there's any
distinction between climate alarmist and
most cultists it's that you can only
string
most cultists along for so long
historically most Cults at least most
apocalyptic Cults disband once the cult
predicts a doomsday and gives a specific
date then the date passes without any
asteroid impact or anything like that
but the climate cult is different they
can make prediction after prediction and
even though they're all wrong they get
to keep making more predictions they get
to keep flying in private jets to
climate conferences where they lecture
us on how to behave what cars to drive
what food to eat what stoves to use and
so on and in the meantime the corporate
press will defend them a reporter for
axios uh recently responding to
criticism that um all of these private
jets might harm the environment wrote
this on social media quote to all those
complaining about world leaders flying
to attend a meeting on climate change
you're not saying anything original fact
is you can't do a zoom call with 190
countries and face to-face talks move
the needle the
most the actess reporter never explains
why a big Zoom call wouldn't be possible
exactly he also never explains why some
of these world leaders can't fly on
Commercial planes you're just supposed
to accept it because ultimately they
have the power and you don't and that's
the actual
explanation a couple years ago at
another climate Summit John Cary himself
made that basically explicit watch it's
the only choice for somebody like me the
time it takes me to get somewhere I
can't sail across the ocean I have to
fly to meet with people and get things
done but what I'm doing almost fulltime
is working to win the Battle of climate
change it's the only choice for somebody
somebody like me says John KY somebody
like me that's what it really comes down
to he's just too important to follow the
rules that you're supposed to
obey that's because the rules really
have nothing to do with the climate or
with global warming or anything like
that the point of all the regulations is
to establish that people like John KY
and his friends are superior it's a
hierarchy that they are
establishing in the end really that's
what all this has always been
about if you like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there God speed